hello and welcome to our conference call
MBA admissions insights being a great
applicant thank you for joining us my
name is ari Chazz Knopf I'm the
communications manager in the MBA
missions office I'm joined by my
colleague Elizabeth Cutler an associate
director here hi everybody so in the
next thirty minutes we'll be talking
about steps you can take to be a great
candidate for the Stanford Graduate
School of Business MBA program and then
we'll answer some of the questions you
submitted in advance first let's discuss
what being a great candidate even means
absolutely for us that's about
identifying people who will be great
students while are here on campus and
who will have a meaningful and positive
impact wherever they go once they
graduate so what steps do you think
people can take to be a stronger
candidate well here are some thoughts
based on interesting questions people
have asked me over the years there's
there's lots of different ways people
think about this you know one is focus
more on being a great candidate than on
creating a great application believe it
or not we want to make the process as
simple and efficient as we can for you
and we only ask for what we really need
to know to create a great class that
said I know the application process
takes so much of your time and energy
like anything you really want it takes
hard work and a lot of heart to be
successful at it but sometimes I get the
impression when I'm talking to people
that someone's letting the application
process take over their life so if you
spend every extra minute in your year
leading up to the application studying
for the GMAT or the GRE what aren't you
doing so for example given the choice
between taking on a great new project
and spending 24/7 on your application
take on the project it will give you a
recommender more to talk about it will
give you the kind of growth opportunity
that will help you become a better
student
once you arrived was as if I've heard
people ask I've got an exciting new job
opportunity doing something I've always
wanted to do but everyone's telling me
to stay in the same job till after I get
into school even though I'm bored yeah
I've heard that one too a great
candidate for us jumps on opportunities
if you're ready and excited about it do
it don't do it to impress us we're
perfectly happy that you stay in your
current job for whatever amount of time
that makes the most sense what I'm
talking about is someone who is ready
for a change but using the application
process as an excuse not to do it you
know you really want to get out and live
your life and that makes you a great
candidate obviously I want you to put
the time and effort in for a strong
application what I'm talking about is
knowing when to draw the line you know
what's the marginal benefit that's a
word you learn maybe after becoming an
MBA for some of you of taking the GRE
one more time or rewriting your essay
one more time if you think at that point
you can really improve either your score
or your essay or your application
definitely spend that time but if you
reach that point where you know deep
down you've done your best and you're
just worrying over it move on you know
we think you should follow your
interests take the risk to try leading
someone or leading something learn from
your successes and failures and apply
that learning to doing it better the
next time step up for challenges and do
an excellent job those are the things
that will show up in your
recommendations and show up in who you
are and get us excited
so you're saying do what you feel
strongly about not just what people tell
you we'll help you get into business
school yes absolutely
don't let anyone else tell you what we
want or that you should shape your
career decisions which are so important
and so personal around the application
process you know yourself best if you
want to know what we want come ask us
that's why we travel around the world we
do this webinar we answer the phones and
we
information on our website always go to
the source whether that's us or another
school about what the school is really
looking for great what else do you think
could help people be a good candidate
well so one thing is we hope you'll show
us your best self just make sure it's
yourself that it's really you being
yourself as opposed to what you think we
want you to sound like or what other
people are telling you you should sound
like and the other is I think the best
thing you can do is really research the
schools just like you're doing by being
on this call today know why you want to
come to Stanford what would you get from
this experience and what makes it a good
fit for you because then you narrow down
and only apply to the schools that are
really good options for you and that'll
show up in your application too so if I
am a great candidate what else do I need
to do to actually demonstrate it you
know are there logistics of submitting
an application or you know how are those
important yeah I get the impression that
sometimes people spend too much time on
some things and miss others here's some
examples of things people may miss one
is just following instructions literally
making sure you've read through the
instructions and follow them
another is to be aware of the deadlines
so very often people will try to submit
information like another test score or
another recommendation or things like
that after the deadline and we don't
accept it the other thing is to review
the entire application ahead of time so
you know what to expect so I think
sometimes people will work on the things
they know about like I need to get our
letter of reference but they won't look
at all the different sections of the
application and make sure they've got
everything that they need so I think
that's important and the last one on
that is to make sure you're putting your
best foot forward and presenting
yourself well but be true and factual
about your experience we do validate the
information you submit before you can
become a student and we can rescind an
offer if you misrepresented yourself so
you do want to be careful about that
you know there are all kinds of great
students some inside the classroom some
in extracurricular activities on other
contributions to their class in the
school there's really no one mole for
the perfect Stanford MBA student so true
and yet they do have some things in
common
so let's quickly review our evaluation
criteria we'll just touch on this
briefly since you can learn more about
this on our website right so the first
one is intellectual vitality what are we
looking for there Elizabeth the way I'd
really encourage you to think about this
is Stanford's a vibrant place it's a
place to solve big problems and take
intellectual risks so we're really
looking for someone that is
intellectually engaged in whatever the
one or many topics are that catch their
attention mm-hmm well next evaluation
criteria is demonstrated leadership
potential what is the reason behind this
one well we aim to graduate students
with an increased ability to lead you've
seen our motto change lives change
organizations and change the world it's
the only way you can go out and create
changes if you can actually lead so
we're both looking for what skills you
may have now and how open you are to
learning new ones do you know what makes
you a good leader do you know what you
aren't good at at all it's okay if you
don't have much experience yet but a
great candidate is at least performing
well at work or in school so they're
likely to be in a position to advance
later in their career and be able to
lead ok well the third criteria we
consider is personal qualities and
contributions what do we mean by that
this is the hardest one to explain
there's no right or wrong answers to
this it's a way of saying that we're
interested in getting to know you we
don't seek to put people in boxes and
don't have any quotas or anything so we
look at each individual we consider what
they might gain from our program and how
they might contribute to the program
fantastic so now let's move on to
answering some questions from
participants thank you all for
submitting so many questions in advance
so here's a question we received many
people talk about the importance of
distinguishing oneself from the majority
application process with regard to the
essay questions what are some of the
most common mistakes made by the
majority of the applicants who are not
admitted so these the answer to this
changes year to year of course I would
say these days the main one is pushing
your own agenda rather than just
answering the question we asked and
frankly even some of the people we admit
are doing this are making this mistake
so be really careful about the advice
that you take on essays even if it's
from someone who got in because you
don't know if the choices they made
contributed to them getting in or were
an obstacle to the to our making a
decision to admit them really the main
thing for you to do is take the time to
reflect read the question carefully
reflect on the true answer for yourself
and then spend the time trying to
articulate your answer rather than
thinking about anyone else and
distinguishing yourself from anyone else
because you don't know who else is
applying and what they're saying and
that's just about impossible to do
mm-hmm second question how would you
evaluate leadership potential in
candidates whose professional roles
don't give them opportunities to
demonstrate it for example in
entry-level positions or positions where
they don't read a team or if they have a
non-traditional background yeah so I
think this is an important question
because so many of our candidates don't
actually have a leadership experience
yet or or anything very formal it's not
important you don't have to have work
experience coming in and you don't
specifically have to have leadership
experience we're looking at the
qualities that you do have and how they
might contribute to your your
effectiveness as a leader we're looking
at your self-awareness because a good
leader is able to learn from situations
around them and it
their behavior and actions those are
some of the ways I would start looking
at it and the other thing is don't get
tripped up thinking we're only looking
for formal leadership experience you
know it might be this how you help
someone next to you at work or something
many many candidates are coming from
situations where they don't have
leadership opportunities yet okay here's
a question of a candidate's GPA
how can applicants confident in their
academic ability but with a poor
undergraduate GPA demonstrate that their
intellectual capacity discipline
academic rigor is not limited to their
past academic performance okay so we're
not evaluating your GPA alone we're
looking at your whole transcript we're
looking at things you've done since you
finished undergraduate if you're not
still a student
so the question I'd ask you is what
leads what leads you to believe that
your let's see your intellectual
capacity or discipline and rigor are
different than your GPA shows what
evidence can you demonstrate to show
that to us because that's what we're
looking for we want the evidence that
you can succeed in the classroom and
that you contribute to your classmates
so that's what you want to think about
mm-hmm great so here's another question
what are the best ways to engage as an
applicant from abroad to learn more
about Stanford and help Stanford get to
know me yeah definitely a challenge so
first of all I should make it very clear
that we don't expect you to come visit
campus anything you can do to learn
about us is great but it's all for you
so you can make a good educated decision
about us we're not evaluating you based
on whether you've been involved with us
or attended anything that said we are
traveling literally all over the world
this
and take a look at our website if see if
we're coming somewhere near you or close
enough that you can get so you can meet
some alumni and an officer in person and
really learn about the program we
encourage you to do that and then really
it's our website you know dive in Ari's
created amazing opportunities to learn
more about the program there like the
day in the life and other things so
really focus on how you can learn about
Stanford you don't need to do anything
separate in order for to help Stanford
get to know you that's really the
application so the only way we're
getting to know candidates is through
the application we don't expect people
to do anything else and to keep it as
fair as possible we're evaluating
candidates based specifically on their
application not on any outside factors
like whether you're coming to campus
whether you know anybody none of that
mm-hmm fantastic the next question does
it matter what age or point in life I'm
in I have a vision and direction I want
to go in but I don't know what it's
going to look like in terms of job
function or company it's a little harder
to answer you know it doesn't matter
what age or point of life you're in to
us it absolutely matters to you and so
the way it matters is you really want to
be thoughtful about why you want to be
in the program and what you want to get
out of it and be able to articulate that
for us we're completely neutral about
the where you are part it's more about
where you are and where you want to get
and how we can help you with that so if
you have a general vision and direction
you want to go and then help us
understand what that direction is and
why you think coming here will help and
why the MBA program specifically will
help you definitely do not need to know
what exact job function or company
you'll notice our RSA to question is
more about Stanford it's not about your
short and long term goals we don't ask
that because
no it's gonna change as soon as you get
into the application process and
certainly by the time you're a student
so we think that those longer term
visions and aspirations are more likely
to remain stable and that's what we're
really interested in well here's an
interesting question someone is asking
can you help us understand what happens
behind the scenes after I submit my
application sure the key things that you
need to know really our first of all
it's a real human being that's reading
your application it's not an algorithm
I've had people who create algorithms
for a living not believe me but it is
actually a fact so it's a real human
being it's me or someone like me that's
interested in getting to know you our
readers are not faculty or students
they're all paid staff and it's a well
trained well calibrated group so there's
no randomness in here it's a
professional group of people reading
your application you know we read it we
decide whether you'll make it to
interview and ultimately whether those
interviewed will receive an offer great
the next question is how do I strike
excuse me how do I strike a good balance
between communicating the value I'd
receive from the program versus the
value I can contribute to peers well
first of all that's a really great
question I'm so glad you're even
thinking about it
I don't even know how to answer it
because I mean you all you all you need
to do is answer the questions we asked
and that's not specifically a question
we've asked so I think you know
it's it's really especially up to you to
focus on what you are here to learn and
I think will pretty much assess what
value we think you can contribute it's
not a question that we ask so but really
great that you're thinking about it and
I hope that you're contributing to the
people around you wherever you are and
that also makes you a great candidate
great point so the next question is
about the three evaluation criteria we
recently discussed the GSB website talks
about the importance of three criteria
intellectual vitality demonstrated
leadership potential personal qualities
and contributions where is the best
place to communicate these in the
application process yeah again that's
totally it doesn't one thing doesn't
correlate to another those are the the
things that I keep in mind as I'm
evaluating every section of the
application so you know we might see
more intellectual vitality showing up in
your transcript where we're really
looking at what you studied and why but
truthfully it can come up anywhere in
the application and the same is true for
all the other criteria so they don't map
to specific locations in the application
really there are things that shine
through can shine through anywhere and
it really depends on you and your
answers fantastic well we got a high
volume of questions submitted in advance
so we have about 13 minutes left so
let's move on to some additional
questions Elizabeth how would you
recommend a candidate reference personal
or professional relationships with GSB
alumni in their application is there a
special way to go about doing that well
no I'd be wondering why you're I guess
I'm wondering what's behind the question
is it that you're trying to demonstrate
that you know somebody here if that's
the case I you don't need to and I don't
necessarily even encourage you to do so
it's not a requirement it's not one of
our criteria if there's something you
learned if there's a reason so for
example if the GSB alums you've met are
the reason you're implying or there's
something about them that stands out to
you and that's part of your decision
process then that could be relevant for
you to share but otherwise it's not
really I don't recommend you go out of
your way to do it at all I've had people
ask me for a reference someone I know
really well and they thought well as an
alum it would be really helpful to hear
from you and I actually suggested they
not waste their time so really focus on
getting references from people who know
you well and can speak to your
performance at work and don't worry
about the alumni factor great next
question is about reviewing one's essays
what is the recommended process to
review and re review your written
statement how do you recommend going
about that yeah so we have no
recommendation it's totally your own
process some tips I've heard from people
are things like you can give it to
someone who knows you really well and
say you know hey if you read this essay
would you know it was me does it sound
like me and that's a way to make sure
it's really your authentic voice another
thing you can do is you can give them
the essay without the question on it and
ask them did they what question do they
think you answered that's a really great
way to make sure that you've answered
the question
what I'd be careful of is getting too
much feedback there or having other
people guide your process anyone who
starts to tell you what we want what
Stanford wants is probably misguiding
you so really focus on
it sounds like you and whether it
answered the question and and also to
make sure there's no lingo in there you
know have somebody who doesn't know your
industry or very much about your work
take a look at it because anyone should
be able to read it and understand it
they don't shouldn't have to know
anything about the business you're in
great advice so the next question is
what if I live in a country that has few
opportunities for minorities to show our
skills how can I show that I'm a well
qualified applicant despite my lack of
awards ah well first of all I'm so this
question makes me a little sad and I'm
really sorry that anybody feels they
don't have opportunities to show their
skills or be their best and I certainly
hope that coming here would you'd have a
very different experience we don't
expect any specific awards so you don't
need any to to apply you know I think
the most important thing to understand
is that we have the people who are
reading your application have extensive
experience we understand different
cultures around the world different
cultures within the US different
cultures within different organizations
and that those environments impact what
opportunities that you any one of us
have and just like we understand that
transcripts and grading systems are
really different all over the world so
we're gonna get some insight just based
on your application about that and we'll
try to calibrate our reading accordingly
and understand the context in which
you're operating and the other thing is
sometimes it comes through in the
references
sometimes references give us an idea
about the context you're in and what
challenges you may have in that context
and that can be very useful as well
fantastic
here's another question about a
candidate's age this candidate says I'm
a 40-plus applicant is there anything
important for a candidate in this age
group to consider I don't think so I so
age isn't one of the factors we consider
what we're looking at is what have you
contributed
how are you performing at whatever level
you're in so whether you're currently a
college senior or you're two years out
or five years out or twenty years out or
whatever it is we want to see what
you're actually accomplishing and what
your impact is and we might expect
slightly more impact from somebody later
in their career than earlier in their
career just because they've had more
opportunity to create such an impact
that's really the only thing comes to
mind for me I think people ask a lot
about like the average age and they
forget that that's really a function not
of our decision process but of who
applies and people typically are
applying at a different stage of their
career but we're really excited to see
anyone at any stage of their career it's
just one more kind of diversity we can
add to the class great so here's a
question from someone who has already
applied to the program and is reapplying
any advice for re applicants who did not
get interviewed in general any general
advice for rioplatense sure well first
of all we welcome reapplication
I was talking to a student who told me
it was his fourth time that he got in
and he's having a great experience and
the reality of it is that we only have
such a few number of seats in the class
relative to the number of people
applying and and so we have to turn away
great candidates every year and we
welcome you to come back and and take
another try
we will look at your application fresh
in the pool of candidates that are
applying when you apply so we're not
looking back at your previous one and we
don't want you to either we want you to
really take it fresh
you're an essay
like what matters most do and why may
not have changed it may have changed
because you've thought more deeply but
we you can certainly reuse an essay like
that but you want fresh recommendations
you really want to approach the whole
process fresh don't let the fact that
you applied before and had a negative
outcome dominate your process just think
of yourself as a new applicant just like
we would great so the next question is
relevant to candidates who have
experience in the military how does the
admissions committee consider the role
of mandatory military service
particularly if it occurred before
college and then second part of that
question is what is the single most
common mistake that military applicants
make during the admissions process so
we're aware that in certain countries
there's mandatory military service and
we see obviously from every applicant in
that country or in some countries every
male applicant in that country will see
that mandatory service we are interested
in what you did during that time a lot
of times it can be a great opportunity
to explore your leadership skills and/or
observe other people in leadership roles
in a different way than you do in daily
life but we don't look at it any
differently than any other application
so we're still looking for the same
criteria and all candidates regardless
of what their specific path is and in
terms of a single most common mistake
military applicants I don't think there
is one people are so different
regardless of what background they're
coming from so I don't think there's any
one thing I see there right I think
yeah we've lots of strong applicants I
don't nothing comes to mind
okay I think we have time for just a
couple more questions so this next one
is about diversity here on campus the
question is how does the GSB work to
create an intentionally diverse learning
community
how do applicants best demonstrate their
diverse backgrounds and experiences in
their applications well it's an exciting
question it's it's one of the big
challenges for us and an exciting one
because we really have the opportunity
to put together a class where people get
to know so much about each other and
frankly they learn lots of things about
each other that we didn't know in the
application process too and I think
where people sometimes get hung up here
is that they they very narrowly define
diversity and for us we look at it very
broadly so every aspect of who people
are come comes into play and yeah
there's no like categories or anything
so how to demonstrate your background
and experience I you have opportunity
throughout the application to just again
all you have to do is answer the
questions and it just shows up you know
I think sometimes people are applying
and they know other people are applying
and they think how can I possibly
distinguish myself we're all the same
but the thing is you're most likely to
be most like the people you know already
that you they might be working in your
company of your industry they may be
your friends but we're actually seeing a
much bigger broader pool and so we don't
necessarily see
as a challenge and this year in our more
about you section there's actually an
opportunity to specifically share how
how you think your background or your
perspective has had an impact on your
experiences so that's another place as
well great point so this will be the
last question that we take in this
session Elizabeth our students that
apply for deferred admission evaluated
separately or differently from those
applying for direct enrollment no
they're not
that said so basically all candidates
are reviewed together in the round in
which they apply but the one difference
is that obviously we have a set number
of spots for next year's class and so as
we get to round 3 we have much fewer
seats to offer and gets more competitive
but for deferred admission we don't have
that limitation and so for college
seniors anybody applying that qualifies
to deferred admission you can actually
apply in round 3 because it's not gonna
be more competitive then it'll be about
the same throughout the rounds but
that's about it the application process
and the evaluation process are identical
great well we're almost out of time if
you didn't get your question answered
today feel free to contact our office by
email or phone to ask your question
before we go Elizabeth
any last word for our listeners today in
terms of how to be a great applicant
sure my one last thought is that one
thing our students really have in common
is that they all applied you can't
change the world if you aren't willing
to fight the odds thanks Elizabeth and
thanks to you all for joining us there
is one more MBA admissions insights
conference call coming up it's called
considering a joint or dual degree and
it's on August 31st so if you are
considering doing
dual-degree try to join us for that one
you can register for it on our website
in audio recording on all of our
conference calls including the one today
will be posted on our website in the
next few weeks you can already find two
up there the current application is now
available through our website there are
three application deadlines September
21st January 10 and April 5th there are
lots of ways to learn more about our
program and the admission process on our
website you'll find videos of past
webinars and a calendar of on and off
campus events we look forward to reading
your application enjoy the rest of your
day and good bye hi everybody thank you